For years, the top of the billionaires list
has been dominated by various tech moguls
from Bill Gates and Mark Zuckerberg to Jeff
Bezos and Elon Musk.
On May 24, 2021 though, Bernard Arnault, the
CEO of LVMH dethroned all the tech moguls
and became the richest person in the world
with a net worth over $190 billion.
So, here’s how a fashion tycoon was able
to beat out the owners of the largest tech
companies in the world.
Taking a look back at Bernard’s roots, he
was born on March 5, 1949 in Roubaix, France.
Unlike his peers at the top, Bernard was not
only born into a well off family, but an opulent
family who ran a well respected construction
business within France.
Bernard never really had that much interest
in the construction business; Bernard’s
true passion was always music.
But he was also practical and knew that it
would be nearly impossible to make it as a
concert pianist.
Then again, he did eventually become the richest
person in the world, so maybe he would’ve
made it as a concert pianist as well.
Anyway, Bernard chose to go the safe route,
deciding to get an engineering degree instead.
Bernard would attend one of the most prestigious
universities in France: École Polytechnique,
and he would get a job at his father’s construction
company in 1971.
That same year, Bernard visited the US and
this would accidentally turn into a pivotal
point in his career.
While in New York, Bernard would ride in a
taxi, and in an attempt to start up some small
talk, Bernard would ask the taxi driver if
he knew the president of France.
The taxi driver replied that he didn’t know
the president of France but he did know Christion
Dior.
Ironically, 50 years later, the average American
still doesn’t know the president of France,
but we all know about Christian Dior.
This exchange showed Bernard the international
recognition of French fashion design, and
it made him extremely proud to be French.
For a moment, he dreamed about running a French
fashion company that was known around the
world.
But once again, Bernard was extremely practical,
and he knew that starting his own fashion
brand would be nearly impossible.
So, he simply got back to work with his father
after returning to France.
Over the next couple of years, Bernard would
convince his father to transition the company
from being a construction company to being
a real estate company.
And as the real estate company grew, Bernard
would become the company’s president in
1978 at age 29.
After taking lead, Bernard would attempt to
expand the company to America in 1981, but
these efforts wouldn’t last that long.
You see, in 1984, the parent company of Christian
Dior, Boussac, went bankrupt.
And the French government was looking for
a buyer.
At the time, Bernard was quite wealthy, but
he had nowhere near enough money to buy a
large brand like Christian Dior.
He knew that this may be his only chance to
buy the company though, so he started talking
to some bankers.
Bernard would eventually land on Antoine Bernheim
from Lazard financial services who agreed
to buy up the rest of Boussac and let Bernard
run the company.
Bernard would end up buying Boussac for $80
million out of which he supplied $15 million
and Lazard supplied $65 million.
As soon as the acquisition went through, Bernard
got to work.
And as we previously discussed, Bernard was
extremely practical, and this required him
to make ruthless decisions.
Bernard didn’t really care about Boussac,
the only reason he bought the company was
to acquire Christion Dior.
So, his first order of business was to revive
the other companies owned by Boussac and then
sell them.
He started off by firing 9000 employees and
dramatically leaning up the various businesses.
He would then flip these businesses for a
total of $500 million.
This was extremely uncharacteristic of French
businessmen at the time who generally prioritized
empathy over profits.
This wasn’t necessarily because they were
super nice individuals.
They did, however, care a great deal about
being viewed as empathetic businessmen.
Bernard didn’t really care about creating
such a perception though, and he just ate
up all the criticism he received from the
media.
One of the most iconic names given to Bernard
by the media was “the wolf in the cashmere
coat.”
Bernard would just continue on his path though,
and his next goal was to complete his Christian
Dior acquisition.
He already bought most of the brand when he
bought Boussac, but the perfume division of
Christian Dior had been previously sold to
Louis Vuitton Moet Hennessy.
So, Bernard still had to buy back the perfume
division to complete his acquisition.
In order to accomplish this, Bernard would
befriend the leader of the Louis Vuitton Brand.
At the time, the leaders of the two brands
Louis Vuitton and Moet Hennessy were having
a major fall out.
Bernard would side with the Louis Vuitton
boss to oust the leader of Moet Hennessy and
get himself into the company.
Eventually, he would turn on the Louis Vuitton
boss as well, making himself the leader of
LVMH.
He didn’t have any equity in the business
though, so building up equity would be his
next target.
Bernard would pour in all the money he made
from flipping Boussac’s businesses, and
he would garner additional funding from Lazard
to buy a significant stake in LVMH.
By 1990, Bernard was able to take control
of LVMH.
Let’s just keep in mind, 6 years before
this, he was trying to expand a family real
estate company to America.
So, between 1984 and 1990, Bernard went from
a generic real estate businessman worth tens
of millions of dollars to being the CEO of
LVMH worth hundreds of millions of dollars.
That’s really quite a transition, but Bernard
was just getting started on his luxury French
empire.
Over the next few decades, Bernard simply
went on a buying spree picking up any and
every fashion company he could get his hands
on.
Some of his most notable purchases include
Celine in 1996, Sephora in 1997, Bulgari in
2011, and Tiffany & Co just earlier this year.
Today, LVMH owns an impressive 75 different
brands which are divided into 5 major sectors.
The first sector is Fashion & Leather which
is dominated by Louis Vuitton.
The second sector is perfume and cosmetics
and this sector is dominated by Christian
Dior.
The third sector is Watches & Jewelry and
this sector is dominated by Bulgari.
The fourth sector is selective retailing & other,
and this sector is led by Sephora.
And finally, the last sector is wine & spirits
which is dominated by Hennessey.
Despite this meteoric success, Bernard Arnault
has had his share of major failures as well
such as his attempt to acquire Gucci in 1999
which is known as one of the most bitter fights
in corporate history.
In 1999, Bernard decided that he wanted to
buy Gucci.
Gucci valued their autonomy though, and they
weren’t looking to be acquired.
So, Bernard would just go onto the open stock
market and start buying shares of Gucci.
He started off small, buying just 5% of the
company.
The CEO of Gucci at the time, Domenico De
Sole, was promptly notified of the purchase
and De Sole instantly knew what this meant.
Arnault promised that the purchase was just
a small passive investment, but De Sole saw
right through this facade.
The Gucci board would immediately organize
a meeting, and they would discuss the two
ways this could play out.
Either Bernard would make an offer to buy
the entire company or he would continue to
buy shares from the open market until he could
force an acquisition.
Bernard chose to go with the second option
and he would quickly accumulate a stake in
Gucci through the open market and a private
deal.
In just a couple of weeks, LVMH would up their
stake to 26.7%.
Soon after Bernard would have a meeting with
De Sole during which Bernard would ask for
3 seats on the board.
De Sole would reject this offer, and Bernard
would just continue to buy up more shares
of Gucci, upping his stake to 34.4%.
This move was on purpose and was designed
to put massive pressure onto Gucci.
You see, the creative director at Gucci, Tom
Ford, had a contract that allowed him to leave
the company with no penalties if any one individual
were to garner a 35% stake in the company.
Having no choice, De Sole would offer Bernard
two seats on the board, but Bernard would
reject this offer.
Bernard would go on to call a special meeting
with the board members which he could do because
of his large stake in the company.
Knowing what this would lead to, De Sole would
simply give in and offer LVMH the opportunity
to buy the entire company for $85 per share.
Bernard could have picked up the company right
then and there, but Bernard would decide to
show some mercy and he wouldn’t take on
the offer.
Meanwhile, De Sole would come up with a last
resort idea that would end up saving Gucci
from LVMH.
De Sole would create an Employee Stock Ownership
Plan.
This plan entailed diluting all the shareholders
of Gucci and creating stock that would eventually
be awarded to employees.
The creation of the employee stock ownership
plan increased the total amount of Gucci stock
available by 42%, and this subsequently reduced
LVMH’s ownership of Gucci from 34.4% down
to 20%.
Bernard was obviously furious, but he didn’t
think he was going to lose Gucci.
He simply thought that Gucci wanted LVMH to
pay a premium to buy the company.
So, Bernard would start negotiations with
Gucci as to who would purchase the newly created
stock.
But little did Bernard know that De Sole was
actually talking with Francois Pinault who
is the leader of the Kering Group.
And De Sole would end up selling the 42% stake
to the Kering Group for $3 billion.
After seeing this, Bernard would become livid
and he would sue to block the deal.
LVMH would offer $85 per share to buy the
entire company and LVMH would argue through
the courts that Gucci must consider their
offer.
The courts would agree that Gucci must consider
Bernard’s offer, but that Gucci didn’t
need to take their offer.
Gucci would end up rejecting Bernard’s offer
and they would choose to sell the 42% stake
to the Kering group for $75 per share.
The Kering group would go on to buy the rest
from LVMH at $94 per share in October of 2001.
Both sides would end up calling the outcome
a victory.
Gucci was able to avoid being acquired by
LVMH, and LVMH was able to profit $700 million
by flipping the shares to the Kering group.
But in reality, I think Gucci unfortunately
lost this battle because they ended up diluting
their shares and still getting acquired anyway.
Throughout the 2000s, Bernard would attempt
a similar strategy with Hermes, but he would
eventually end up backing away from that acquisition
as well.
At the end of the day, though Bernard did
have some sour deals, most of his acquisitions
have gone on without a hitch, and this has
allowed him to build LVMH to be the largest
fashion company in the world and the 18th
largest company in the world with a market
cap of about $400 billion.
With a 46.84% stake in LVMH, Bernard has successfully
built up a fortune worth just under $200 billion
today.
What do you guys think about Bernard’s vicious
series of acquisitions?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you guys thought this
video explained Bernard’s story well.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.